hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well Albert Camus
begins his philosophical treatise the
myth of Sisyphus with a lapidary line
there is but one truly serious
philosophical problem and that is
suicide a position that he will change
later on in life but which runs
throughout this entire work why say that
suicide is the philosophical problem par
excellence well because it has a sort of
finality to it and it goes to the very
roots or depths of our being and our
attitude towards ourselves the universe
other people it has to do with the
question of the meaning of life does
life in fact have any sort of meaning or
value the way that he frames it judging
whether life is or is not worth living
amounts to answering the fundamental
question of philosophy the question that
places all the other ones within some
sort of framework because if you say no
and you commit suicide there aren't any
other questions it's done but if you say
yes then there's the possibility of many
other questions and Khemu points out the
you might say in
consistency's of some other philosophers
he talks about Schopenhauer who
recommended suicide and said that the
life is not worth living continuing to
live he talks about nobody is willing to
actually die for the ontological
argument and he even talks about Galileo
saying Galileo who held the scientific
truth of great importance absurd it with
the greatest ease as soon as it
endangered his life the truth was not
worth the state and he's not actually
criticizing Galileo there he's saying
actually Galileo made the right choice
in in that case why frame it in terms of
suicide why just not asked is life worth
living or not well because if you think
that life isn't worth living then you're
afraid you're your post or framed within
a a philosophical structure in which you
have to make some sort of decision and
come who points out that not everybody
is completely consistent in this but
we're kind of a mess so he talks about
how suicide has been looked at as a
social phenomenon and here he has in
mind you know some of the studies of for
example Durkheim looking at it as a
sociologist and when we think about this
we often frame it in terms of causes why
why do people kill themselves today we
frame it in a large part in terms of
bullying particularly cyberbullying we
might also think of people losing
meaning in their life because of
illnesses or loss of relationship or
loss of political power or the loss of a
job or it could be that they never
really had that much to lose to begin
with and they've had forced upon them
unjust social structures that then
caused them as we think to do that and
come who points out really if we think
about this in an individual manner we
have to look at the relationship between
individual thought particularly thought
concerned with the absurd
and suicide and he's got some really
interesting lines here he says an act
like this is prepared within the Silence
of the heart as does a great work of art
the man himself is ignorant of it one
evening he pulls the trigger or jumps
and that's the case some of the time
people you know find themselves you know
making that decision at that point in
time but there's always a whole network
of causes he's got another great
observation here of an apartment
building manager who'd killed himself I
was told he'd lost his daughter five
years before that he had changed greatly
since and that the experience had
undermined him a more exact word cannot
be imagined beginning to think is
beginning to be undermined so it's not
just that bad things happen to us and
you know tear us down and perhaps put us
into depression you know there's all
sorts of traumas that we may incur but
it's also the fact that we we think
about things and Camus will actually
tell us at one point something that I
suppose some people may find
controversial but strikes me as quite
true that every person has thought about
it all healthy people having thought of
their own suicide he mentions doesn't
mean that everyone's going to act on it
but it is a constant possibility insofar
as we are creatures with agency and
insofar as we are creatures who can
understand our own contingency and can
think so when he's talking about the
causes he says there's many causes for a
suicide generally the most obvious ones
were not the most powerful rarely in
suicide committed through reflection
what sets off the crisis is almost
always unverifiable newspapers often
speak of personal sorrows or incurable
illness and he says these explanations
are plausible but if we started probing
into the causal framework one would have
to know whether a friend of the
desperate man had not that very day
addressed him indifferently he says it's
hard to fix the precise instant and it
is easier to deduce from the act itself
the consequences it implies so
here he talks about suicide as being a
sort of confession
what is it confessing according to Camus
what it's confessing is that life itself
understood as one's life or the totality
of life is too much or it's not
comprehensible he says it's kind of
confessing that life is too much for you
or that you do not understand it and
then he says let's not take this analogy
too far let's think it through right
it's confessing that it's not worth the
trouble living he says is never easy you
continue making the gestures commanded
by existence for many reasons the first
of which is habit dying voluntarily
implies that you've recognized even
instinctively not necessarily on a
conscious level the ridiculous character
of that habit the absence of any
profound reason for living the insane
character of that daily agitation and
the uselessness of suffering does this
cover every single instance of suicide
we can ever think of it would take a lot
of work to show that to be the case but
in in the main we can say that Camus is
is on to something here when somebody
decides to end it it's because there's
some sort of decision being made a
decision about the value or dist value
or lack of value altogether of life and
he frames this in terms of the absurd he
also says that this is not such a
straightforward question you know yes or
no life has a meaning doesn't have a
meaning what do you think he says the
problem may seem simple and insoluble
it's wrongly assumed simple questions
involved the answers that are no less
simple so he says seems that there's
just two philosophical solutions either
yes or no but this would be too easy
allowance must be made for those who
without concluding continue questioning
some people say ah I don't see a meeting
right now but let me hold on and maybe
I'll find a meaning later
or they say boy man it really looks like
it doesn't have any meaning right now
but look let's see or they say I think
it has a meaning it's not one that I
completely fathom but let's see if it
turns out to be wrong right people defer
it in one way or another he says I
noticed also that those who answer no
act as if they thought yes there's a lot
of people who mope around and say how
life sucks so much and you ask them well
you think life is so meaningless
why aren't you ending it and the answer
is on some deep level they don't really
say no they're really saying no on a
surface level when they mean yes on a
deeper level and Here Come who brings up
Nietzsche this he says if I accept the
Nietzsche and criteria and they think
yes in one way or another
what is the Nietzschean criterion look
at what people actually do he also says
on the other hand it often happens those
who commit suicide were assured of the
meaning of life you know what what would
be examples of that well think of some
of the philosophers who actually
committed suicide like Socrates who
drank the hemlock he you know he in
effect committed suicide at the order of
his political community that of Athens
who had sentenced him to death he
administered the fatal draught right or
Seneca who committed suicide at the
order of the Emperor Nero that if he
hadn't committed suicide then a lot of
other things would have happened to
other people as well and or you can
think about Cato another stoic
philosopher killing himself so that
Caesar couldn't used him in any way so
there's there's cases of people who do
see a meaning to life and act upon that
and we could call those tragic
situations right those aren't the sort
of things that Camus is talking about
here he's talking more about people who
say there isn't any point to all of this
and then they end it
so the question that we're faced with is
does the absurd and this
that's the Tate suicide and there's a
lot of different ways in which we we can
think about this so one way of thinking
about it is life is absurd we grasp the
absurdity the disconnect or the divorce
as Camus is calling it between our
desires and our thoughts and the rest of
the cosmos and we say ah it's it's it's
all garbage I'm going to end it and then
I won't suffer from this anymore this is
an act that I can do and that's one
possibility right
another thing that he's going to talk
about is what we can call philosophical
suicide and he says now I can a little
bit later
I can broach the notion of suicide it's
already been felt what solution could be
given it was previously a question of
finding out whether or not life had to
have a meaning to be lived it now
becomes clear on the contrary it'll be
lived all the better if it has no
meaning
now not everybody embraces that and he
talks about in particular the
existential philosophers he also
includes some phenomenologist in there
as well and he talks about the
possibility of what he calls
philosophical suicide this is not
killing yourself for the philosophical
draught of poison or knife or anything
like that rather it's it's looking at
the absurd and using the absurd in some
way to justify something that would be
an escape from the absurd finding say
the world to be irrational and saying
well we're going to just going to
embrace that irrationality and we'll
have an irrational ism or taking some
other you know more restricted basis and
saying philosophy is really just about
this we're not going to think about
these great questions or its embracing
the absurd and using the absurd as a
sort of
of you know we talk about this term deus
ex machina god from the machine right
it's sort of an escape valve a leap of
faith a way of getting some sort of
meaning out of meaninglessness embracing
the absurd for its own sake and saying
well is it's okay
right it's it's great that is actually
turning your your thought off that's
going up thinking up to a certain point
and then refusing to think in a
connected way to everything that's going
on before after that you take the leap
into whatever it is the irrational faith
the absurd and that solves everything
for you
Camus considers that a cop-out that's a
form of philosophical suicide another
thing that he thinks is a bad solution
very closely connected is to embrace
some sort of hope
Camus thinks that we need to live in a
universe without hope and you might
think you know for example of other
philosophers who he is criticizing again
the existentialist s-- as he understands
them often are embracing a kind of hope
that he sees no no good reason for no
logic to it's just an escape or there's
finally the solution that he embraces
which is to say that life is absurd but
that doesn't have to mean that we commit
suicide whether physically or
intellectually or emotionally
instead we live in that absurdity this
is not the same thing as embracing the
absurd this is not the same thing as
valuing the absurd this is instead to
say the absurd is what we're dealing
with and what are we going to do we
maintain it in existence in our thought
but we also revolt against it so he says
living in experience a particular fate
is accepting it fully no no one will
live this fate knowing it to be absurd
unless he does everything to keep before
him the absurd brought to light by
consciousness negating one of the terms
of the opposition on which he
is mounts to escaping it to abolish
conscious revolt is to elude the problem
the theme of permanent revolution is
thus carried into individual experience
of permanent revolution a social theory
he's saying this is a problem for the
individual particularly the kind of
individual that he wants to be and to
advocate
so he says living is keeping the absurd
alive and keeping it alive is
contemplating it this is one of the
possible answers to this this
fundamental philosophical question not
committing suicide not because life has
a meaning but precisely because it
doesn't have a meaning and that means
that we don't have to do that and it's
actually better in some way at least if
we like to be consequent to ourselves
and consequent to our experience if we
don't do that if we remain with the
absurd and he goes on and he says this
is where it is seen to what a degree
absurd experience is remote from suicide
it may be thought that suicide follows
revolt but wrongly it does not represent
the logical outcome of revolt it instead
he says it's just the contrary by the
consent it presupposes suicide like the
leap is acceptance at its extreme
everything is over and man returns to
his essential history in a way suicide
settles the absurd it engulfs the absurd
in the same death and here's what Camus
lays out his position I know that in
order to keep alive the absurd cannot be
settled it escaped suicide to the extent
that is simultaneously awareness and
rejection of death it is at the extreme
limit of the condemned man's last
thought that shoelace that despite
everything he sees a few yards away on
the very brink of his dizzying fall the
contrary of suicide in fact as the man
condemned to death and he says that this
is what gives a person you know human
dignity and pride in the greatest amount
so
a answer that Camus is providing to the
philosophical problem of suicide is to
say yes life is absurd yes we are absurd
absurdity actually embraces these two
polarities of us and our experience and
yet we can decide for ourselves to live
through that experience to not simply
reject it or come to terms with it but
to revolt against it which means to
maintain it there and also to say no to
it in a way that's dynamic and continues
through our existence
you